[Music]
zach is in omaha nebraska hey zach how
are you
[Music]
going to be honest been a little better
we got word today that my dad is
probably not going to leave the hospital
alive
so
trying to figure out how to help my
family through this a little bit more
because there are like i know what you
guys usually recommend but they're not
really plugged into you guys and i'm
trying to figure out how to guide them
through
the
coming weeks oh zach i'm sorry what's
wrong with him
i
i think it's some kind of blood
poisoning issue i'm not 100 sure every
time a is in that date she
writes like a book so i've lost track of
all the
diagnosis going on
how old are you how old is she
i'm 27 my dad is 60.
oh my goodness okay
um
well here's the thing it's um
when when you're facing something that's
this emotional
the um and this devastating
um
the more facts you have
most people it lowers our anxiety
um gathering the facts might temporarily
increase some people's anxiety in the
mix
but the overall family will be better if
they have good solid facts people are
much more afraid of
the unknown than they are of bad news
and that would include the financial
story that's here okay
the unknown is much more scary than
even the known that i've got some
struggles with okay that makes sense
yeah that's kind of why i call because
like my mom
there's some financial things that we'll
need taken care of right away and stuff
like that but also
like you usually tell people my mom
needs time to just be able to sit there
and cry and she's got my 14 year old
brother living with her
plus i i got a 23 year old brother who's
living there with his wife and two kids
and i know at the very least one of the
things they want to do quickly is
replace the house because they live in a
fallen apartment double wide that
even i don't really want my mom living
in anymore because it's
junk at this point yeah okay
um all right um so really there's three
major
categories or three buckets that we can
address
one the first one is do we know the list
of
things that they own
and things that they owe
they own uh the house we bought cash for
like three grand and we remodeled it
ourselves there's a small construction
loan with my dad's pickup as collateral
i don't know the exact amount my mom
won't tell me
she has a ford expedition i
if i had to guess i'd say
at minimum 10 000 on that
they got a couple credit cards i don't
know if they're current on payments or
if they have some debt on those
and uh does your mom work i think that's
about it
uh yeah she does okay the second bucket
is
to begin to put together a budget of how
she will live
if he doesn't come home
financially
how's she gonna eat
keep the lights on
what's gonna be the game plan that with
the monthly budget what's the monthly
budget look like if he doesn't come home
um that's the second case
i'm gonna guess roughly three thousand
dollars yeah and then maybe
you said you said she works and earns
what
uh uh that that's specifically her
income my dad was on disability for the
last little bit i don't know if she's
gonna get any financial
i don't know if he's got life insurance
i don't believe he does i think he lost
it when he lost his job like six years
ago and uh so let me help you with this
all three answers to all three buckets
so far is
i don't know
okay i don't know what they owe she
won't tell me
i don't know what it takes for her to
live and how much she has coming in
towards that
and i don't know if there's any life
insurance
so i go back to my original statement
would you agree with me zach that not
knowing is more scary than knowing
admittedly yeah like that's where i
guess that was kind of the point i was
going to try to get out with this
question is i've got those are pretty
educated guesses so my answers are
somewhere around the numbers i gave but
i don't know and mom's pretty stubborn
about telling me anything related to
finances as if she's trying to do it on
her but like she seems to feel like she
needs to do it on her own to an extent
and i'm trying to figure out how to let
her know you're not alone and i know
i've screwed up with my finances but i'm
i've learned a lot and i want to at
least help a little bit yeah
okay why don't you just say that
um
you're not alone
i know this is scary
and i know you're a strong independent
woman
would you allow me to be a shoulder you
can lean on for a short period of time
and let's walk through putting together
a plan to where you can operate on your
own
but i'll help you develop the plan
[Music]
okay and and if she responds
if she responds to that with a stiff arm
there's nothing you can do then
you can't help people who won't accept
the help
even your own mom
your little brother needs to get a job
and move out today
he's a burden he's not a blessing
not the 14 year old the 23 year old with
a wife living in a trailer with his
mother
to be fair he does have a job
why they won't move out i will event i
don't know yeah well i just said what he
needed to do i didn't say i didn't give
a reason why other than it's ridiculous
yeah and so this is not a blessing it's
a curse it's a problem
and and but but again none of these
people
are required by law to take your input
or mine
and so
um you you
it's very difficult to insert yourself
forcibly into an adult
who has legal rights into their
situation without their permission the
one thing i want to throw in there zach
is um these next few weeks and months
are going to be so hard on all of you
all
if you offer to help
once
and she says no
you can keep offering it does not hurt
to come back around two weeks and be
like hey i'm here but what hey i'm here
but what i don't want you to do
is to try to help a where you're not
welcome or be where you have incomplete
information or cooperation yeah
if she says i'm not doing that then you
go okay yeah but but if if she may come
around she may come around a couple
weeks after trying to do it herself and
she wants help but might be too proud to
ask for it if you're there going hey i'm
here if you if you need someone i'm here
you know would love to walk with you in
this and then she may be more receptive
the other thing zach um and and dave
talked about this but uh
you may not your brother may not listen
we can talk to him you want to help your
mom talk to him and get him out
like you you are
exactly what you said dave you are a
burden
you need to be on your own
you need to get your own place it's
going to make a lot easier to take care
of mom and help mom if you're not having
to deal with all that you and said wife
need to be working 60 hours a week and
being on your own and then me and my
wife me and myself are going to help mom
as well to the extent mom will let us
yeah
but we're not going to be a burden on
her anymore
and um you know and it sounds like some
stuff's going to have to be sold to
clean up the mess would you you know and
it's a dumpy place and they want to get
out of there sell it and go rent
something
but you know go rent a little
two-bedroom apartment for her and your
little brother and um that'll give your
older brother or your middle brother a
reason to leave yeah because there's not
a place for him at the new place
but again
your mom if she's gonna stiff arm you
and play the tough independent i don't
need help
uh john wayne routine there's nothing
you can do
all you can do is what christy said just
continually say i'm here when you want
help i will tell you what will drive her
nuts and you nuts is either you forcing
yourself into a situation where you're
not welcome
or
she gives you only a little bit of
information and you try to act on that
and so you're playing around the edges
and you can't really get to the core of
the problem and that's not gonna do
anything but frustrate her and you
so if you if you're gonna help it needs
to be all in
if you're gonna stand on the sidelines
it needs to be all the way on the
sidelines